I'm not a scientist or a doctor but is
my understanding that it is more complex
than what you are saying in that there
is
variation among men and among women and
sometimes more variation um among than
there is between now I want to show you
video of Fatima Goss Graves she is
president of the National Women's Law
Center and here she is uh unable to
answer if there are differences between
men and women
genetic composition of a transgender
versus a woman the
same no well I'm not a scientists well
we're talking about science here so you
mean I hope you they're not the same so
that's why you see all these
physicological differences if I can
answer though I I mean if your question
is um how do you define woman a woman is
an adult female but there's a lot of
variation that goes beyond my level of
high SCH bi tell you you can't I'm not
looking at a definition I'm talking
about the science the science
genetically is a man is a man is a
different genetics than women plain and
simple that's just what it is I I guess
what I would say is that it is I'm not a
scientist or a doctor but is my
understanding that it is more complex
than what you are saying in that there
is
variation among men and among women and
sometimes more variation um among than
there is between again I'm not a
scientist and you know I don't think the
panelists are scientists either seems
like maybe a different scientific
hearing that you well that's why you
have the differences that's why you see
muscle mass that's why you see title
volume that's why you see all these
right there variations so for example in
the WNBA there's players that are 5 foot
five and there's players that are um 6'
n wide variation now that you brought
that up now that you brought that up
let's talk about that so uh the center
for the the Arizona Phoenix Mercury she
had to get a genetics test to proved
that she was a
woman did she not you know what she did
and it's actually going to the problem
with these sorts of sex veric
verification and sex texting that um
when I think about what all women but
especially uh
black especially black women okay there
was so much Insanity there that it
really is hard to to unpack it but I
will try first off again that woman is
the president of the National Women's
Law Center and she can't say what a
woman is lady look down you got a you're
a woman you got a you're a dude I'm not
a
scientist I've been operating on that
theory for a long time and and most
people have that'll pretty much solve it
for you that's number one number two she
then compares the varying ways that one
might Define a woman comparing comparing
that to height if you're 5'4 and you got
a you're a woman if you're five foot n
and you got to you're a woman do we have
to keep going here or did we make the
point made one more if you're 6'4 and
you got a dong you're a
dude